the most important foundational
technology of our time artificial
intelligence
could an artificial intelligence can
imagine these I'm not sure about what's
going to happen next
bang the search engine that everyone
knows about but no one uses or at least
that's what we all remember it as Bing
has actually been making quite a bit of
progress against Google especially in
the desktop Market at the end of 2018
Google had a market share of 91.46 while
Bing had a market share of a mere 3.36
percent but by the end of 2022 Google's
market share had fallen to 84.08 while
Bing's market share Rose to 8.95 in
October Bings market share almost even
crossed 10 and looking at the trend it
appears that this will happen within the
next couple of months now of course
Google is still by far the most dominant
player but at the same time we can't
just write off this trend as random
Market fluctuations either given the
massive size of the desktop Market over
5 billion people around the world have
access to the internet and even if we
assume that only half of these people
use computers to access the internet
that's two and a half billion people
this means that it Bing's ryzen market
share correlates to a rise from 84
million users to 224 million users also
known as an extra 140 million users
and it's not just market share numbers
that are suggesting this either Google
themselves suggests that interest around
Google has fallen substantially from
their Peak back in 2014. in fact
interest in Google is only about 50 of
its peak which brings us back to 2011
levels what makes this even scarier for
Google is that Yahoo was at the same
level of interest just 10 years ago so
if Google follows a similar path to
Yahoo they may very well be at single
digit numbers in 10 years but that's of
course the worst case scenario and it's
quite unlikely that Google will end up
like Yahoo anytime soon but it does look
like Google's Heyday was nearly 10 years
ago at this point and looking at the
friend it appears that there's just even
more downside ahead but wait a minute
while Google's market share has been
trending down it hasn't fallen anywhere
near 50 so where in the world is all of
this internet traffic going instead
foreign
starting off with the most obvious
culprits we have a competing search
engines and particularly Bing 10 to 15
years ago you could have made the
argument that one search engine is
better than the other but nowadays they
all performed to a pretty high standard
including Bing so practicality is
something that will rarely get people to
switch between search engines given that
they're all about the same but something
that is a pretty good incentive is money
if you're not familiar with Microsoft's
Rewards program Microsoft will literally
pay you for using Bing this might seem
odd at first but it actually makes sense
Microsoft makes money from showing you a
sponsored search results and they simply
assure some of this Revenue with you as
a thank you for every search you make on
Bing you'll earn Five Points and as a
newbie this is capped at 50 points per
day or 10 searches that's just for
starters though if you actually use Bing
regularly Microsoft will boost your
limit to 250 points per day or 50
searches each point roughly correlates
to one cent so you can easily be earning
hundreds of dollars every single year
just for doing what you're already doing
but worth it being there's actually a
bunch of Hardcore Bing users who have
this down to a science this one Reddit
user for example estimates that he's
earning 8.24 cents per hour by just
using Bing normally obviously searching
on Bingo won't replace your job but it
might okay you have free pizza or
Chipotle every month or so and many have
figured it if they're willing to let
Google sell their data they might as
well let Microsoft sell their data and
at least they'll get free food out of it
speaking of data some people still have
hope that they can secure their privacy
online and that many of these people
have chosen to use DuckDuckGo over
Google if you're not familiar with the
duckduckgoa they're a search engine
whose entire pit just basically were
anti-google essentially they don't
collect any data about you and they have
no idea who you even are basically
imagine Chrome Incognito if it was
actually Incognito aside from not
tracking your search history duckduckgoa
also tries to connect you to encrypted
versions of websites whenever possible
but it's not all sunshines and rainbows
at the end of the day duckduckgoa is a
company who needs to make money and the
way they make money is of course
sponsored search results it's simply
that these ads aren't targeted we should
also note that while Dr themselves does
not collect data DuckDuckGo is powered
by Bing or Microsoft they have tried
their best to block as many Microsoft
tracking scripts as possible but they're
not 100 successful nonetheless for many
this is a magnitude better than using
Bing or Google directly for the more
cynical ones well they figured if you
can't fight him you might as well join
them and these are the people that
walked over to Bing
alright so a subset of the population
has shifted over to using Bing and
DuckDuckGo due to their appeals of money
and privacy while this has made a dent
in Google's market share and it's by no
means the biggest corporate the biggest
culprit is actually social media and
it's not just in a few niches either
it's across the board take the how-to
space for example ten years ago you may
have Googled it how to know if you've
been ghosted and read a wikiHow article
about it but now you can sit back relax
and reflect on your field social life on
YouTube Jokes Aside though it was
actually difficult to find high quality
how to's on YouTube for Niche topics 10
years ago but now you can find detailed
videos on literally anything that you
can think of and I don't know about you
but for me following videos is way
easier than following articles and
pictures not to mention more enjoyable
the same thing could be said about the
news as well ten years ago if you wanted
to follow the fed or the stock market
you'd probably have to read the New York
Times or Bloomberg or watch cable TV but
now there's thousands of YouTube
channels Tick Tock Pages Twitter
accounts Discord communities and
WhatsApp groups that are relaying each
and every development faster and more
digestible than CNBC this medium is just
made even better by the fact that it's a
lot more interactive while NBC may have
a massive Euro base you can't just
scroll down to the comments and share
your thoughts or see what other people
are thinking just like half of you are
probably doing it right this very second
we have virtually no way of reaching
someone like George Stephanopoulos or
Jerome Powell but we can't tweet at Elon
Musk and there's actually a chance that
he'll reply and an even better chance
that he'll read it also even if our
tweet it doesn't come across Elon it's
more than likely that hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people will
see it especially if it's something
insightful or funny but social media
making everything more learnable
viewable and enjoyable compared to
Google is just half the story the other
key point to note is that we no longer
search for the content we consume
statistically speaking 82.4 percent of
you are here because YouTube recommended
this video to you only 5.2 percent of
you are here because you actually
searched for it and even amongst the
people who are here from the search
results I bet you sir step logically
answered as opposed to the actual title
of this video this statistic is simply
even more relevant for a platform like
Tick Tock or Instagram where you're not
really supposed to search at all you're
just supposed to scroll the algorithm
already knows what you want to watch
before you know yourself whether it's
infotainment funny memes or thirst traps
and when everything you need is offered
to you without UE even doing anything
well you end up searching far less
while we're all searching for less than
we were 10 years ago there's still a
place for searching sometimes you just
need information fast maybe you need to
fact check something or troubleshoot
something technical you know virtually
all of these cases what you need is in
fancy articles or videos what you need
is raw data and any article or video
that you need to get through is simply
an obstacle not an enhancement while
this was often annoying for decades this
was something that we simply didn't even
question if you needed data fast you
went to Google searched for what you
want scrolled past the sponsored results
clicked on the most reputable website
you could find and skimmed through until
you found what you needed oftentimes you
have to press the back button go into
another article and do even more
skimming to truly find what you needed
now of course this is a first world
problem 50 years ago or even just
without the internet getting information
is literally in million times harder but
with that being said we now have options
that are way better than even Google
Chat GPT for example has been making a
lot of noise recently you just have to
ask it a question and it'll do all their
searching skimming it and compiling but
chat GPT is just the latest example of
this one technology that has already
been part of our lives for years now is
voice assistance like Siri Alexa and
Google these assistants are already
great for getting simple facts like how
old is Joe Biden or what's the weather
like for more advanced questions they
often just direct you to google.com but
that's simply because they're not
Advanced enough yet we should also note
that Apple and Samsung do not redirect
you to google.com out of the kindness of
their hearts Google actually pays Apple
and Samsung an undisclosed amount every
year which is estimated to be in the
billions just to stay the default search
engine so you can bet that once AI
becomes good enough to reliably replace
google.com these guys are gonna be the
first to jump ship now we shouldn't note
that Google themselves will also be
jumping ship so it's not like Google as
a company will be left behind but
google.com will this shift towards AI
will simply be accelerated by the fact
that these AI offerings will likely be a
lot better better at telling you what
you want to hear they'll be able to
cherry pick data points and form
arguments and answers that fit your
perspectives and beliefs this is one of
the main reasons that social media
platforms are so successful in the first
place they're able to serve you content
that you already agree with while this
creates massive Echo Chambers and is
terrible for having healthy discussions
and debates it's perfect for maximizing
user retention and usage and
subconsciously people will enjoy using
these platforms even more and before you
know it google.com will be a relic from
the past
foreign
the search interest around Google has
declined substantially over the past
several years some of this can be
attributed to direct competitors like
Bing and the duckduckgoa but most of
this actually has to do with the rapidly
shrinking search Market While most of us
probably didn't notice on average we
don't search nearly as much as we once
used to because we simply don't have to
we're able to get all the information
that we need from social media and AI
none of this is to say that Google as a
company is screwed by any means first of
all they own YouTube the largest social
media platform in the world they're also
involved in thousands of businesses from
maps and email to operating systems and
the cloud also Google is at the
Forefront of this AI Revolution and are
perfectly positioned for the shift so
Google as a whole will be just fine but
that's why google.com's interest has
been falling off a cliff did you realize
how much less we tend to use search
engines comment that down below also
drop a like if you're excited but also
scared for AI and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community such
as for the video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one